what do you think cancellation is trying
to achieve like what you just explained
there it doesn't seem to work it pushes
these ideas underground in some regard
it can throw them into Echo Chambers
where there are presumably no dissenting
voices what what is it trying to
achieve I mean I think it's just
predicated on a think a fundamental
misunderstanding of how how dialogue
works and how minds are changed in
hearts and and minds are one over I
think I think there's been such a an
alienation from the classical liberal
values post Enlightenment that that made
society free and and made dialogue
robust and made debate healthy and um in
the realm of ideas and not ad hominum
and you know for for example I I've
never learned John Stewart Mills on
Liberty I never learned the importance
of free speech and growing up even going
to Great Schools and doing a Philosophy
degree at NYU I didn't understand the
importance and and just how profound
those post-enlightenment ideals are and
how much they need to be bought into by
the entire culture and community in
order to thrive and I think that those
some people who engage in cancel culture
are genuinely
meped but other people I think do
believe that if they shut down
and I don't know castigate anybody who
has a bad belief that that somehow
actually does expunge it from society
which is provably true I think it's it's
polarized us even further um but I I do
think that it's just because people are
are no longer taught the the importance
of you know he who knows only his side
of the argument knows little of that and
and the importance of being able to
exist in the realm of ideas and then
frankly it's just an easy cheap tactic
to win arguments without winning
arguments because if I can attack you
for being a sis hat white male I don't
actually have to deal with the fact that
you might have an ideological argument
that that Corners me or makes me
uncomfortable in my own
predispositions what are some of the
mechanisms for enforcing cancellation
that people might not realize are part
of the cancellation
machine I would say one thing that
people seem not to talk enough about is
how early it's starting and especially
in the in the social media age I grew up
I had an iPhone when I was 10 or maybe
11 I was on Instagram by the time I was
11 surely and I am now like the human
receptacle for every parents horror
stories about what's happening to their
middle schoolers getting cancelled for
like a two-c Snapchat video or someone
screenshotted something and now
everyone's seen it and I think that one
of the enforcement mechanisms going
forward in the age of everybody having
this insanely excessive digital
footprint and all of their adolescent
blunders being forever immortalized in a
way that I think any older person should
shutter at the thought of um that's one
way that it's being enforced is that
there's an entire generation of young
people who were coming up just
surrounded by trip wires even in their
teenage years that they're arriving on
campus in college already primed for the
fact that they have to self-censor or
that they could be called out at any
point in time and I think that that's
self-perpetuating because that's making
less and less people even want to stick
their neck out in the first place but
then I also think that cancel culture is
is so dangerous and so powerful not just
for the people whose lives are torn down
and completely ruined but also for all
the people around them that see that and
see them having been made an example of
and then will refuse and understandably
so To Tread that same
territory what's that what's it called
like a a a some kind of ideological bias
test that people get asked uh and it's
almost like the culpably deniable
test of of becoming of working out out
where your politics are it's not part of
some uh induction it's not even part of
a code of conduct but people just
sometimes throw a little question like
what do you think about Jordan Peterson
like have you ever listened to Ben
Shapiro have you done know this thing
and that's one of the more sort of soft
introduction ways to this that slowly
over time results in you being
denigrated or or disparaged or made to
feel other and um yeah it's not just
people calling for removal of accounts
and band and protests it's there seems
to be sort of a softer kind of
alienation of people that have different
views which importantly is culpably
deniable right there's no point at which
you've done the thing because I think
that people who are seduced by the
prospect of being a white knight or who
like the idea of performative empathy
because it makes them look moral whilst
having to do nothing moral or people who
just want to enact power and enforce
this over other
people the game is beginning to evolve
in the way that memes often do where if
you it's now low status to be seen as
someone that calls for cancellation
because cancellation itself has become a
meme so now the methods of cancellation
need to become increasingly subtle they
need to develop as the defense
mechanisms develop as well yeah I mean I
think it's it's I think we've seen less
coordinated sort of Twitter mob tear
Downs although I would say that 2020 was
kind of a an exception to that but to
your to your example um or to your point
an example of that would be in 2020 and
after the death of George Floyd if you
didn't post the black Square then that
was a a moral the ideological Ro shock
test yeah exactly and I mean there were
people who I I have friends who were
completely castigated and and and
unfollowed and blocked for not having
done so I I mean I didn't do it and that
wasn't didn't go over too well at NYU um
but that would be the perfect example of
like a a soft like do you buy into to
the prevailing ideology at that point in
time um and I would also say to that
point there's definitely like a a slow
and subtle quaning that I saw of when I
was in um in classes at NYU and in my
more philosophy oriented courses where
it would kind of become clear that maybe
one or two people are a little more
heterodox and it was just like a slow
people are going to start kind of
sitting on the other side of the
classroom when they come in if that
person's over there um to the point
where it was like this kind of
bubble as though we were ill or there
was something wrong with us um and I
I've also watched how growing up that
way has I think polarized young people
even more because if you grow up if
you're being racially segregated when
you're 14 on Martin Luther King Jr day
and you're having political ideologies
shut down your throat from pretty much
day one it's understandable why some
people especially young people become
the reactionary opposite or can go down
some rabbit hole on the internet
um and like I I'm fascinated to see I'm
sure you saw that statistic that um
girls and boys are like forking
politically right now and I think
there's what do you make of
that um I you know I think
it's I think part of it is a little bit
of a reactionary thing for boys and
understandably so I think that I I
tacked right when I saw how weird the
left was around me when I was in school
but I also feel like politics
are there's almost a feminization of the
left a little bit and a lot of
um I think a lot of even cancel culture
or or attitudes about free speech and
and needing to protect other people from
harmful speech almost hijack the the
female proclivity to be more empathetic
or or to um you know emotionally reason
more than rationally reason which is
obviously you know you do all the whole
like on average and of course there are
exceptions to that rule but I mean even
if you look at students attitude on free
speech and the percentages of students
at various schools who will say that
it's sometimes acceptable to respond to
speech with violence
consistently like the top five schools
are all all women's schools with the
highest percentage of people saying that
they would respond with violence to
speech and so I do think that our
political binary is taking on a little
bit of a gendered tone and then you also
just have the the reality of growing up
on the inter and ending up down rabbit
holes which happened to me politically
and I was like all the way on the right
one year and then all the way on the
left one year and it's it's
understandable how how that could cause
a polarization I think for sure in other
news this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't it's a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it is the best
way that I have started my morning every
single day for over three years now it
contains a science backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
with no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink lnt.com
slod wisdom to get a free sample pack of
all eight flavors with your first box
plus there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it 100%
risk-free that's drink LM nt.com
SL modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip then
press here for the full podcast episode
go on press it